how are you doing good yeah I guess I'm
gonna start with the most important
thing do you feel like you use Instagram
too much actually I feel like I under
use it a little bit like it's it's not
use I definitely scroll through it but I
don't post much at all anymore I was
gonna say cuz I like looking at what
people are posting on social before I
sit down with them and I'm like looking
and I'm like you scroll a little bit and
you're back in like 2017 I'm most active
as I used to be I think I don't know I
kind of I think most likely I just I
enjoy people not seeing everything
anymore
true and even so I never really posted
pictures of myself hardly it's more
pictures of what I see through my eyes
every day I completely get it jumping
into Adams family I thought you did a
great job of voicing Wednesday it's so
different than your actual voice it was
like an actual performance yeah you know
so talk a little bit about that aspect
of the character it was it was really
fun I mean that was the big thing for me
as I wanted to feel not like oh that's
Chloe Moretz just saying words I wanted
to feel like this is Wednesday Addams I
really wanted to fit myself into this
different character and it really
started off where my first session I was
really sick and I was really nasal and
we actually ended up keeping that for
the rest of the movie so that's also
Wyatt it's kind of has so much resonance
to it like that because I was sick
originally doing it and I think it
really worked off with a character in a
strange way 100% one of the things that
people don't realize about recording for
animation is that things can really
change during the recording process
right so I'm curious how did how did it
change from when you first started
recording to what people are gonna see
on screen Oh big time I mean we were
even doing changes to it a month ago I
mean it comes out in the month so we
were yeah a month and a half ago I was
doing pickup lines and changing to
dialogue and expanding of certain
moments at the ending sequence the big
ending sequence so I think there's a
freedom to be able to rewrite history a
little bit when you do animation you can
you can you know kind of fudge it a
little bit here and there yeah
which is which is really nice because
then I don't have to actually go reshoot
on a set we just get to go into a booth
and do a couple pickup lines for five
minutes things at home one of the things
about recording is that sometimes most
of the time you're recording by yourself
did you ever record with other people or
no only sometimes you get to record with
other people but on this one I mean
obviously the cast is it's so great and
so wonderful but everyone is really
working consistently throughout the year
so none of us have the time there's a
couple sessions where we almost got to
be in the same room but it ended up most
time the lines on both sides of the
scene change so it's better to be not
locked into each other's dialogues they
can cash change and shift us around and
the scene if they have to completely um
I am very curious I believe you've
either wrapped or you're filming this
Tom and Jerry have you wrapped wraps
okay so I'm very curious about this
Michael I grew up with Tom and Jerry
yeah what what can you tease people
about it oh my gosh I I will say that it
is one of the hardest things I have ever
done it was so fun and it is laugh out
loud funny and you're gonna see a
completely different side to me that
we've never seen before
and it is a really great story and I
fell in love with these two little
characters so deeply and they're just
adorable
and I think everyone's gonna be a little
shocked at how fun it is it's really fun
it's like the wonderful 90s movies that
we don't really see anymore
that are good family romps sure my last
thing for you what what the challenges
of making something like that can you
tease anything about that
I was so challenged I mean I would just
say that it is what you think it is
they're silent characters and so I'm
acting opposite nothing right and trying
to interpret that for the audience so
all the dialogue that you hear is from
my side and it was really me against a
piece of tape recut it which was cool
right honest acting class well thank you
so much for your time and congrats on
this thank you